well what do you know well Fox News
Alerts we're awaiting the possible
sentencing of Paul manna for the latest
is coming up but first so while you're
hard at work what are the Dems up to
arguing over whether they should condemn
anti-semitism what a strange place to be
debating how to condemn hate yet for
weeks they've been dancing around
Ilhan Omar's repeated anti-semitism
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi miscast as
the adult in this comedy pushed a
resolution condemning the slurs but
bowing to the hard left newbies she's
dancing again there's one resolution
addressing these these forms of hatred
not mentioning her name because it's not
about her I do not believe that she
understood the full weight of the words
I feel confident that her words were not
based on any anti-semitic attitude but
that she didn't have a full appreciation
of how they landed on other people where
this these words have a history and a
cultural impact that may have been
unknown to her oh so she's just ignorant
so now they're revamping the whole thing
not mentioning Omar by name but
including all persecuted people this is
how far the Democrats have fallen they
can't even agree to remind people that
they don't hate the Jews seems pretty
easy to me but here's my favorite
argument against the resolution that
condemning hate puts the hater in harm's
way Kamala Harris says I'm concerned
that the spotlight being put on
congressman Omar may put her at risk
sorry senator
the spotlight is what Omar craves the
spotlight is the whole point
besides when the smollett hoax took off
did anyone worried about putting Trump
supporters in danger when people said
red hats were racist did anyone care
that it put targets on innocent heads
did anyone care at all when actual harm
was done
these are trick questions because the
answer is obviously no so a radical
leftist dog whistles away about Jews and
the fear is that criticism of
anti-semitism might put her
in harm's way there roughly a hundred
thousand Holocaust survivors still
living who managed to escape the Nazis I
wonder how they feel about that so
Jessie
I guess it's weird now that if they're
worried that if you criticize
anti-semitism somebody else could get
hurt from I guess enraged Jews so now we
have to worry about Jews assaulting her
is that the case I don't understand this
you listen you're able to criticize
Israel without being anti-semitic yeah
Omar apparently is unable or unwilling
to do that because she's been warned a
few times but this is really all about
Nancy Pelosi Nancy Pelosi has gotten off
to such a bad start
as Speaker she came in the stock market
goes down they shut down the government
the green New Deal has been a disaster
they've suffered nationally from a black
faced controversy and now they're
suffering through an anti-semitic
controversy the bottom line is this
Nancy Pelosi does not want to alienate
these radical freshmen because she fears
them because they have so much juice
they have the grassroots they have the
youth they have the social media and
these people don't want to take a loss
they are they believe they're infallible
and they're self-righteous and they
don't want to play defense they want to
go on full-throated offense against this
president and they don't want any blue
dog demo
dancy Pelosi has lost control and that's
why they're watering this down it's like
John Boehner and the Tea Party couldn't
handle him and he had a huge headache to
deal with and that's what you're seeing
right here so they got the juice which
allows them to bash the Jews very good
Dana this resolution doesn't name Omar
by name so it's an ant but instead their
have their every persecuted group no
it's all hate matters all hate matters I
mean so now we have to come out and say
okay we don't hates bad back yes it's
very clumsy I think the Democrats are
embarrassed by it I think they probably
wish they never would have gone down
this road for this resolution because of
what the the fissures it's exposed and
now because it's being considered pretty
much a joke
who doesn't yes all hate matters all
lives matter like we get we all get that
this seems to me like this one it's a
point of the Democratic Party where you
after kind of wonder also what the
Catholic Church doesn't really have that
much
right anymore right because of all of
their problems institutionally and the
credibility problems now you have
American Jews who have typically voted
for Democrats really having to make this
this decision about do we continue to
support this party if they can't even
say that anti-semitism is bad and I
disagree with what Nancy Pelosi said
there that it's not about her meaning
congressman Omar because this app this
initially started like six weeks ago
when she first got sworn in and if they
would have nipped it in the bud then
they wouldn't be having this problem now
you know can I just say so they remember
when Nancy came in and they said Nancy
was gonna cut off people's heads they
weren't even gonna realize they were
bleeding yeah now Nancy is bleeding she
hasn't been able to execute that you
know Jedidiah
Omar's getting some very strong support
from David Duke she's the most seasoned
em David Duke does she condemn David I
have no idea but he claims he claims
that Omar is the most important member
of Congress amazing that she doesn't
take heat from that though yeah all
right she doesn't take you for that
somehow if that had happened you know
and it did happen I do happen president
Trump and he he T there who she should
ask her it's so amazing though in the
dumb hurts I mean for Nancy Pelosi to
come out and say oh it's not about you
know OMA of course it is and it would
benefit you to say that it is about her
because now people are asking well who
is it about is it about all of you that
you all felt that you needed to come out
and make this this vague odd commentary
about this when in fact all the language
in it if you look points exactly to the
comments that Omar made talking about
dual allegiance so and it also shows a
refusal on their part when someone of
their own rank does something outrageous
like makes an anti-semitic comment
they're refusing to hold that person
accountable all the people in the middle
of the country it may it may make the
base happy the aoc lovers Bernie Sanders
Ramallah Harris but there's a whole
bunch of people in the center of the
country that look at this and say why
did the Democratic Party feel the need
to do this is this are people confuse do
they think the Democratic Party is
representative of eight and it's used
problem so I think they better get there
Nancy Pelosi buddy get him in line she's
been there a long time she's afraid of
the newbies and it shows hey wonder as
you can see there right there stir I
should look this way there the voting is
starting even though I'm actually
looking at Dana the voting it look at
the voting over there why what why the
obsession with Israel among the young
people coming in here is this something
that comes from academia I want to
understand it is it is it because they
don't understand the language the
language that they're using yeah I think
in her case she's unfamiliar with some
of these anti-semitic tropes but to me
that's this is not the issue I think
they want to have honest conversations
about American policy in the Middle East
and what they're running into is people
saying oh you know what she used these
anti-semitic tropes and therefore we can
ignore the larger topic and I think when
you have people like Yellin Omar coming
in to the Congress you know we have the
first two Muslim women and suddenly
their perspective on Palestinian human
rights is introduced people say oh wait
we haven't heard this before no let me
ask you what is the larger topic I said
II said is us sorry policy in the Middle
East and with regard to Israel so you
get Bernie Sanders who's Jewish saying
don't equate anti-semitism with
legitimate criticism of the Netanyahu
government in Israel Elizabeth Warren
branding Israel at the equivalent of
anti-semitism criticism of Israel is
anti-semitism is chilling in an American
democracy and here's Jay Street a Jewish
lobbying group the biggest threat to the
Jewish community is white nationalism on
the right that Trump has unleashed both
in the US and globally but what you get
from Republicans is the light in this
problem for Democrats rather than saying
you know when Trump says to a group of
Jewish businessmen oh yeah you want to
buy your politicians and control them or
when Kevin McCarthy goes after Soros
steyr and Bloomberg is buying election
we don't hear anything from the Republic
which Democrats expect Trump every time
Trump says something they don't like
they expect Republicans to hold Trump
accountable the American people to hold
Trump accountable now you have a woman
who would think whether she meant to
talk about Israeli policy or not her
comments it's all about the Benjamins
this is stuff that has been universally
condemned they now has suddenly have a
problem putting her in a resolution no
oh you should condemn your side they're
condemning anti-semitism and until they
hold her accountable guess what Howard
she's gonna do about it if they are
condemning hatred why are Republicans
having such trouble because Republicans
aren't interested in condemning hatred
they're interested in condemning
Democrats and Omar what they're saying
oh no don't do this you got to really go
after Omar wait a minute that's why you
see leading Democrats saying is this
about silencing legitimate criticism of
Israel thing and absolutely smearing
that is what we saw in West Virginia
with that poster you're deflecting on
about Republicans when this is a
Democrat issue
you didn't answer Greg's question Greg
specifically asked about u.s. foreign
policy why is there an obsession with
Israel and you didn't answer why is it
about Israel one country in that region
there are tightest I like the human
rights record is so above and beyond
yeah wrong
Saudi Arabia but I don't hear criticism
of those countries you only see
criticism of Israel are you kidding me
you think I ran Ian's human rights
abuses Saudi human rights abuses look I
haven't heard her I'm thinking America
speaks out about these issues all the
time because their human rights record
is so horrific but you're absolutely
ignoring Israel's record in terms of
occupying Westbank territories their
treatment of Palestinians and questions
about a two-state solution which had
been America I'm not sorry I'm just not
calling Israel even that's the only
difference one okay what a beginning